Yeah,
I write every day.
I get up around five or so and get two
little kids off to school and then I go
to work around nine and work until four
o'clock or so and then do it pretty much
every day.
Oh,
I wish.
No,
it doesn't get easier.
It gets harder in fact,
because I,
you can't write the same book and that
would,
that's always tempting to making a
sentences is hard work.
You can't copy your own sentences and
you can't copy those of others.
And so you're searching,
you're searching for a certain grace in
a certain rhythm and melody that's
underneath the pros that carries the
story.
Great question.
The first answer that pops in my head is
absolutism certainty.
I'm certain about very little in this
world and I just trust those who are,
they have a,
I feel a stinker.
The smell of,
of a blinders and of,
of uh,
compacity and pretentiousness that for
me,
a companies,
uh,
certainty or a little bit of hype.
Hypocrisy also weaves its way through
absolutism.
And there's so much of it around us on
television.
Every talk show seems to have it.
And in the real world,
I'm always encountering people who
declare things about the world I live in
with the certainty that I just don't,
don't see around me.
And in my writing that shows.
That's why the issue of truth appears so
much throughout all of my books that I'm
skeptical of.
Well,
what's declared to be true?
I don't think pride is the right word.
I look,
I look at the book now 20 years after
having written it with a sense of
dissociation.
I find it hard to believe that those
stories are mine and those sentences are
mine.
And in a way they aren't any longer.
They're part of a world of literature.
A book goes out and it takes on its own.
I want to say it someone life,
but it's the own,
the about illness and identity that is
divorced from the person who,
who made it.
And I feel sometimes even now,
but like a fraud that I know I wrote the
book and intellectually I know it,
but,
um,
it to read,
it surprises me at times,
phrasal surprise me or an event will
surprise me and come at me a bit,
little bit as a stranger's voice does.
And in a way,
I am a stranger.
The person who wrote that book,
I'm 20 years older and I've had 20 years
of,
of new experiences,
children and things I never had before
that make that old voice seem old.
No,
no way.
It's life is eerily,
and uncannily echoed that final chapter
of the block where the timmy,
that little kid at the end of that book
was a forerunner to the author who wrote
the book.
It's an effort,
uh,
as the story says at the end of say,
little timmy is life.
I A little boy who grew up in a small
cow town in southern Minnesota and found
himself in a entangled and in Vietnam,
but not just in Vietnam and in hard
moral choices that it never had occurred
to me I'd ever faced in my life.
And the little naive lone ranger playing
timmy that became that soldier in
Vietnam was a kind of stranger to the
guy who wrote that book,
the the middle aged me.
And just as now the author of the book
seems a bit of a stranger.
Um,
by bid off,
I mean,
I,
I'm not talking mysticism.
I'm simply saying that,
you know,
20 years is a long time to pass and,
and uh,
well when a sense of self changes,
I think of myself now primarily as a
father and secondarily as a writer and
I've heard those words come out of my
mouth.
20 years ago it would have been
impossible.
It didn't want,
kids didn't think it would be very much
fun,
didn't think it would challenge me.
I thought it'd be kind of bored by it.
And now that is more of my life then,
then a writing.
It's nothing intelligent behind it.
That is,
it wasn't a rationally planned
operation,
but rather it's how the world comes at
me.
He comes at me and a mix of my
imagination coming over here to do this
interview.
I'm imagining will I meet and what will
it be like?
And I've never done a video interview
before.
And what will the physicality of the
place be and all these and partly the
real world.
And I think that I'm not all that
uncommon in that.
I think we all live partly in our
daydreams.
And daydreams is the wrong word because
it makes it sound syrupy and mystically
I'd met,
but I partly mean daydreams and I partly
mean just thought or anticipation of
event that hasn't yet occurred.
And I think we all live there and you
certainly live there in a situation such
as a war where you're partly,
uh,
the reality of the world is in your
face.
But partly there's the wistful call of
girlfriends and home and all the things
you don't have yearned for,
where you're living,
partly your imagination.
I'm not in a war.
And you'll flow in and out of these two
the way you would maybe in a cancer ward
or if your marriage is collapsing or
your father has died or you're partly,
he had the stark reality,
that corpse in that coffin and you have
partly remembering your dad's face as he
threw you a baseball or were even more
poignantly to,
in my case,
the wished that he were saying,
I'm throwing you a baseball.
Kind of the invented throwing of a what
wasn't.
So I guess what I'm saying is that I
didn't like,
like everything.
I don't,
I didn't,
didn't plan in a cerebral way.
The form of the things they carried,
it took advantage of what was natural to
me.
I mean intentionally knew what I was
doing,
but I was taking advantage of what
really is pretty natural to me.
I live in at least those two worlds of
imagination and a world we all live in.
Well through story.
Essentially what you hope is that when
you do what I do and you write novels,
you're hoping for for a sense of feeling
to come through in the end,
that through nonfiction the brain is
engaged and the head is engaged
primarily not always just that,
but primarily and with fiction telling
invented stories.
The hope is that through the story or
read her lying in bed at night or you
know,
reading a book on the subway or the boss
will sort of leave the bus and leave the
bad and be transported to Madame Bovary,
his bedroom and you're kind of as there
half a witness and half a participant in
a story.
And my hope is that those who read the
things they carried in my other books
too,
you hope that they'll feel sure.
That identification thing that happens
in a story where you're rooting for
people are,
you know,
hoping the villain is cod or whatever
your emotional take on there.
You're in it.
And not just observing it the way you
observe CNN or you observed the Fox
channel,
let's discussed.
I don't think I've ever tried to resolve
it.
I think it's one of those things that
kind of resolves itself when I speak
about Vietnam or when I write about it,
I'm not my own,
uh,
selfhood kind of evaporates.
I'm interested in what's occurring on
the page and I'm interested in what's
going to become of these characters.
And I'm interested in the moral
struggles they're going through.
And I don't,
I'm not like my attention is on the
making of a,
of an object in a way,
an artifact the way a sculptor may look
it up,
use of stone,
and you may have a vision for what you
want that stone to become,
but part of what you do is it's the
stolen kind of lead you to what it's
going to become.
Vain of minerals may run through it and
then,
oh,
that's there.
That could become this.
And that's been like writing fiction and
a bit of dialogue may pop out of the
character's mouth that's unplanned and
unintentional on my part,
I have no volition over.
It seems to,
uh,
Peter,
well I know that I'm coming from
somewhere inside my head and my history
and my imagination,
but it doesn't affect,
it doesn't feel as if I'm willing and
I'm making it happen by volition.
It's appearing.
Uh,
stories have a way of,
of pulling you along,
kind of chasing the story as you're
writing it.
And it,
it,
it doesn't feel as if I'm playing that
old childhood game of connecting dots
that they've all been planned and I'm
just going to write sentences to connect
it all.
It feels more as if I'm on a,
on a riverboat and watching people and
scenery go by and a novel or a story has
that feel of a,
of a voyage in which I'm partly a
participant in partly a witness.
I wish I could say yes cause it sounds
so much big thinking,
but it is the act of writing for me is
largely the act of following sentences
and making sentences.
And for most people that probably is a
time to click off and look at something
else.
But unfortunately for me,
stories grow out of a sentence.
For example,
the sentence,
this is true.
Again,
one of my stories I wrote the sentence
was I had no idea of what,
what was true.
True.
In what sense?
I had no idea.
And I wrote another sentence to follow
that.
But a buddy in Vietnam,
he and Bob Kiley,
well I'm discovering,
I probably discovering and a partly just
curious about,
are fascinated about issues of what,
what could be true and what does this
character going to say is true and does
this character really mean it?
Does it really mean it's true?
And uh,
to what degree does this character think
it's true and how could anybody say this
is true and real without a little tongue
in cheek action going on?
So it's a,
it's a discovery.
And what I think was one of my better
stories grew out holy,
out of the unplanned,
out of a scrap of language is forgotten
by readers.
I think that are largely forgotten that
that are 26 letters in the alphabet and
some punctuation marks.
And that's all we've got.
And that is what I work with fitting in
my underwear day after day,
year after year,
I was 26 letters.
He's punctuation marks and out of that
character is calm and moral quandaries
are explored but in the end the work of
writing and fortunately I was really the
battling with Abcd and that's comma that
so in calcitrant there are those and it
doesn't,
it's not a function of age and it
probably wasn't even a function entirely
of of uh,
education or political leanings.
But there's a,
there's a temper in probably America,
but for sure I know in America and maybe
worldwide for the literal,
a literal take on everything that that
reality TV is taken advantage of and
incorporated as part of itself.
And the literal take on things is a take
without irony,
without edge and without,
it's usually a fairly,
there's a certitude to it.
Why don't you write a book that has
nothing to do with war is that that's a
certain possibility and you should
certainly try to do it as a way of
recovering from the war.
And you want to say a number of things.
This is not just a book about war,
you idiot.
And it's a book about love and a book
about storytelling.
But you also feel overwhelmed by,
by the knowledge that you're not going
to get through.
That's the literal minded are going to
remain literal minded and maybe someone
else can help them,
but that someone else,
not,
not this guy.
So there's a,
there's a wave of anger or bitterness.
It has to do with Vietnam,
has to do with a kind of mindset of the
literal all around me that doesn't fit
my take on the world.
It's a,
in my experience in the world where it's
hard for me to take anything very
literally boards.
I love you.
I have there as soon as they're uttered,
I'm suspect.
How much and when will you stop and will
you,
um,
in what way do you love me?
And what is love to you,
by the way,
is that forever or is it still an ex,
you know,
person,
passenger,
all this stuff complicates where someone
else's I will love is love.
And if you don't know what it is,
you're really,
you're poor guy.
And that's their take partly is to,
I probably,
I tried to skewer it at parody it,
make fun of it,
ridicule it and put it in his place.
Partly I'm,
I'm sympathetic to the literal that is,
I'm sympathetic with some mom is holding
a dead kid in her arms and how else is
she to take it?
But here's my dead child.
And so there's a part of me that
understands it and is sympathetic to it.
And probably the better part of me is
that why,
where I have that at least at least some
capacity to,
uh,
asic much novelists kind of have to have
to imagine otherness outside oneself.
And as a consequence of my books are
filled with characters who bear no
resemblance to me and,
and can be villainous in ways I'm not
villainous.
And it can be good in ways.
I'm not good that I think the capacity
for,
for empathy or understanding goes with
the successful book because you have to
create other characters and other angles
of vision on material for the,
for a book to ring it ring with some
kind of authenticity among my fellow
soldiers in Vietnam.
I mean there was and remains to this day
kind of absence of that kind of empathy
or a dead child as a dead [inaudible]
dead Vietnamese woman or one of their
legs blown off was a woman with goop,
with their legs blown off.
And it pretty much remains that way
these days,
40 years later,
those same buddies I served with in
Vietnam don't have much empathy for the,
uh,
so called enemy and I doubt they would
be capable of because,
because that's there,
if you know,
writing the things,
they carried it write another book that
wouldn't be a,
it would be a much different book.
I ran into a kid in Seattle or kid,
26 year old,
um,
at a book that,
a book signing and I saw him out of the
corner of my eye standing in the corner
and was kind of frightened by him.
Not In physically,
but I mean,
Oh God,
I hope it's not a manuscript he's got to
give me and that which is hell of course
to,
and the guy that finally this reading
Andoni hung around and I could feel him
out of the corner of my eye approached
me and he had me sign his book and I
did.
You began to leave and then he turned
around and he said,
I think he knew my father.
And as soon as he said those words,
I knew who the kid was.
I saw it in his face,
his cause he was dad and that kid's face
who was my platoon leader in Vietnam.
Uh,
and he told me over the course of the
next,
I don't know,
20 minutes or half hour that he had,
the kid had been searching for his
father ever since.
His father committed suicide soon after
Vietnam.
And,
uh,
had looked for his dad in very brave,
cool ways.
He had joined the army just to see what
his father had gone through,
really become a green beret.
As soon as dad had been a ranger,
all this tuff snake eating,
you know,
the stuff.
And he had picked up my first book and
there's father figures in the book,
not been always in the most laudatory
way is in fact not in laudatory ways.
Well,
that encounter,
I mean,
if we want to cry,
if I weren't on camera,
I'd be a little tears in my eyes now
because it's an example of why I began
writing in the first place.
I don't want to touch people in a way
that,
that stories can touch him.
And I had helped in a very modest way
for this fellow to fill in a gap of who
this man advantage committed suicide
before they even knew his father.
His father killed himself when he was
very,
yeah,
I think it was like six months older,
eight months,
very young.
Um,
encounters like that.
Remind me of why began.
It's easy to forget why you,
why you become a writer.
Letters I'll get from me,
the girlfriends and people in Iraq or
Afghanistan or the children,
which all say the same thing.
Basically.
I don't know,
my dad,
he won't talk about it or my mom in some
cases,
but largely men.
And we,
I read your book and now I know at least
something and when he's carrying around
with them and what do you won't talk
about.
And sometimes the book will be shared
with the veteran and conversation will
ensue.
And that is way beyond anything I
intended hinder writing in that book.
I didn't intend to bring people together
or it's Darren,
I'm talking.
But it shows you the power of,
of literature.
It can,
it really touches individual people
realize and the real world and
contributes to their lives.
It does something to their lives.
Uh,
that,
that's what I dreamed of.
I began riding home,
dreamed of touching some 15 year old kid
and dubuque or some grieving mother.
And you know,
Harlem,
Eh,
literature makes you feel if it's any
good,
it can make you feel a little less alone
in the world.
Someone else has gone through this and
it gives you some late night company.
Um,
with your memories and your thorough
literature is,
does touch people.
It's not just to be read in English
classes.
You can't physically put a person.
I mean,
I've,
I've often thought of what a cool movie
would be.
For example,
if you go to a war movie and they out of
the screen come real bullets and you're
ducking and you'd get a where it's not,
you're not shielded by the knowledge
that I'm not going to die in this movie
house,
or,
or at least that's not,
the bullets aren't going to do it.
Um,
and you can't do that,
that,
that you rely as you probably do in
anything you're relying on,
on the human,
the reader or the audience's imagination
to just sort of suspend the knowledge
that I'm not going to die inside this
book or at this movie.
But you have almost start to seduce the
reader or the audience into almost
forgetting that,
almost forgetting that feel of danger
and,
and a good work of art.
There's a movie called the Messenger
that's recently come out about the,
with Woody Harrelson and Ben Foster.
It's,
and it's not,
it's a war movie and away,
although none of it happens in war.
It's the notification of next of kin
where they knock on doors and say,
your son's dad or your husband's gone.
And although,
you know,
in the theater,
it's not just,
you know,
they're actors and so on.
There's a bluntness and a brutality in a
horror to it that some of those way
beyond John Wayne stuff and the actual
war stuff,
which has a,
you kind of expect what's coming.
And so Laura,
people are going to die and you harden
yourself to it and they do.
It's a different experience to watch
those knuckles on the door and that fate
door open.
And if that face,
that person die in front of you,
that mother,
um,
that,
that is,
um,
what are just for,
that's what it's for.
It's for cutting through rhetoric and
cutting through politics and cutting
through convention to,
uh,
open a trap door in your soul,
the avowed purposes behind our or
preemptive in more and Iraq or let's get
rid of weapons of mass destruction.
I think I'm pretty clear on my memory on
that.
Well,
there weren't any,
and it's a bit like,
let's go to war because we were attacked
at Pearl Harbor.
It's a Pearl Harbor hadn't happened and
I'm astonished that this large seemed
largely forgotten.
Seems are raced from the public
discourse about the war.
I don't hear many people going on
television saying we went to war for
reasons that didn't exist.
I don't,
I don't feel any outrage coming from
anybody I hadn't done.
And I don't,
not only do I not feel it now,
I never felt it.
Um,
I find that stunning and I do here
instead as well.
We,
we got rid of a tyrant,
Saddam Hussein.
The problem with that is that in the
first place,
that wasn't the reason we went to war.
They didn't do know,
didn't go before.
The United Nations is saying let's get
rid of a tyrant.
He went before saying their weapons of
mass destruction and there was no
tyranny stuff there except in the most
second hand and trivialized kind of way
more.
But beyond that,
there's a thing called consistency.
And there's another thing called
hypocrisy.
And if the object is to get rid of
tyrants around the world,
why aren't we nuking Red Shyna what we
used to let the Republicans used to call
Red China and why aren't we at war with
half the countries in Latin America and
why aren't we taking half the countries
in Africa if not more than half?
Um,
and there are no answers to those
questions.
Sort of Cherry pick your war and go get
rid of that tyrant.
And then there's the question of ty,
ty origin,
whose eyes,
I mean,
and what if for example,
al Qaeda were to declare a George Bush
is a tyrant and we're going to attack
you or are we all going to say,
okay,
come tax us.
It's okay to attack tyrants.
Who declares that the tire.
It is who we are.
Well we have,
we've been elected as a country to
decide who the tyrants are and who the
good guys are.
Um,
those are complicated questions and
they're not addressed and not even
looked at anymore.
And,
uh,
it,
that's part of where my frustration
comes,
I think in,
uh,
writing about this subject is I feel
that things have been de elevated in
that the discourse is aimed at a really
low,
low place and difficult questions are
not just not answered.
They're not even asked.
And they aren't asked by,
don't seem to have been asked by the
people who uttering the bellicose
rhetoric of war.
You seem to be alighted innovated.
Um,
and then there's the final issue that
kind of attend your question,
which is the issue of personal,
I don't know how to phrase this,
but a pr,
a personal commitment to one's own
rhetoric that the rhetoric of
bellicosity that's or has surrounded,
especially the initial phases of our
intervention in the Middle East.
These people aren't there.
They aren't,
I mean,
you know,
the,
the Cheney's and the,
uh,
the public face and the public,
explainers of our presence in a,
too often they're hiding their kids away
at Yale or you know,
or wherever and they're,
they're not putting their bodies with
their rhetoric is,
it's one thing to sit in a TV studio,
you're cute bow tie and say,
let's go kill people.
It's another thing to go and do it.
And if you don't go send your daughter
or your son,
they got to go and they've got an,
I just go there.
You gotta,
you know,
walk the streets and,
and drive the vehicles and risk maiming
and death and the hypocrisy of saying
it's a great thing to go kill people.
But if somebody,
you go do it,
I'm not,
and my kids aren't,
but you go do it.
After having gone through a war myself,
I find that that's still stirs in me in
the same way it did 40 years ago.
Uh,
an anger that's hard to,
it's hard to keep my voice under
controls.
I'm talking about it now.
Um,
because it seems so dishonest and so
cowardly and,
and uh,
so evil than the end.
It is in part that and part to mimic our
collective memories.
All of us that,
um,
memories of strange thing that if you
think about it,
how much of today do I remember?
Well,
I could,
it's already abstracted,
but I've already hook,
of course,
utterly obliterated almost every
syllable to come out of my mouth.
It's gone.
It's history.
What about yesterday?
I can't remember.
Every dish I washed,
every scab I picked,
every rich person I encountered,
it's,
it's every meal.
I ate three hundreds and thousands of
them.
And I would say that out of my life,
99%,
probably a lot more than that.
It's been erased that I'm,
you know,
biliterate it,
erase canton.
Remember a detail and I'm not just
talking about childhood,
I'm talking about adulthood and people
I've cared deeply about it.
And I remember them and loving ways and
yet have a few snapshots of memory.
And we hold onto those and we call a
memory.
And that's memory,
that little remnant of,
of a lifetime.
That's what's left to us.
And we attach this word memory to it,
which sounds has a sound of encompassing
all but it doesn't and that's certainly
applies to the things they carried.
I mean it's a book partly about memory.
The author of that book is an older guy
and he's looking back and he's recycling
event from different angles,
sometimes inventing things as a way of
seeking that which is,
is gone.
Uh,
you,
you've ghostly a good friendship.
Merrick's who stepped on a landmine and
was blown into this tree and uh,
he's been dead a long and yet in their
writing of the things they carried,
I tried to in some way resurrect through
imagination what his last thoughts may a
man as he soared into that tree,
there's sunlight is killing me.
I know I'm making it up,
but I'm trying to sort of cast a light
on that which has been darkened by,
by a history and the passage of time to
let chip keeps soaring,
you know,
use it.
As long as that book is read,
that Guy's going to keep soaring into
that hedge for,
you know,
under that tree.
And as long as the book is routed,
Little Linda at the end of the book is
going to keep skating on that ice and
little timmy will be in love with her
and the skating along.
And that is what you don't,
you're not.
So I'm not saving their bodies and I'm
not even saving the memories of these
people really.
But I'm saving something.
I hope that's essential and enduring and
the human spirit,
the love of a little boy for a little
girl and a good friend who soared into a
tree and a terrible war.
And that's something,
it's not everything,
but it's something mostly pissed off.
I mean,
I'm a come down on that side of there's
a mythology that accompanies the memory
of an event.
And by and large from my fellow soldiers
in Vietnam,
the mythologies of betrayal,
we were betrayed by government.
They didn't pursue it,
were betrayed by the liberal press.
Uh,
it wasn't our doing.
It was,
they're doing the same way that after
World War One,
the Germans were preached to by the
forces of,
became Hitler.
That,
you know,
you were betrayed after the end of world
war on Germany was sold down.
And by and large,
my buddy's feel that why that a we could
have won the war if only there were more
people weren't killed and more women
raped and more houses burned,
we would have it.
Uh,
I don't think they're right,
but they feel that way.
I don't,
I think you could have paved the country
with the concrete and put up a big fence
around it.
I used to have all these people who
don't watch it.
There you are Americans and were
Vietnamese and this is our country.
And you may have the concrete and the
moms and the technology,
but you're not gonna win us when us,
you may have won a war in a way.
Well,
there's,
I think there were mythologies of,
of memory and my dad carried with him
out of World War II mythology of
America,
the lone ranger and the doer of good and
the carrier of democratic flame.
And,
uh,
there was a head of undercurrent of a,
almost a soundtrack of Frank Sinatra,
Gene Kelly soundtrack running beneath
it,
of buoyancy and of,
of virtue and the soundtrack that ran
beneath the movie of Vietnam.
You know,
you know,
and all your people are going to watch
this smell was not that I'll be seeing
you sentimental journey soundtrack.
It was a soundtrack of the doors and the
stones and it was an edgy and critical
and,
and a much more ambiguous,
a soundtrack that more or less
accurately reflected the ambiguities and
the,
uh,
the absence of a certain moral
underpinnings to that enterprise that,
uh,
so those are two pretty different
edifices of what's called a mythology
about a war and mythology as a way of
eliminating all that doesn't fit into
it.
It doesn't,
you sort of eliminate that part of it.
I think there's probably some truth in
the notion that there is an insidious
and dangerous side of the mythology
that's surrounds Vietnam.
It,
it has a slight stink of the hip and of
the cool of the,
uh,
walking the dangerous line.
And the,
uh,
I think there's a,
there,
there was an exotic feel to the war and
this far off jungle and that was part of
them.
The mythology around it,
it sort of beckon is beckon is one a new
to the adventure and we have my exotic
experienced and dangerous moment that
uh,
that manages to erase the absolute
horror of it all the dead people,
the dead children and just the horror,
um,
that maybe part of what every writer
about war is finally had to come to
terms with in one way or another that
they're pretty great books had been
written,
including the Iliad and the Odyssey that
haven't ended wars and Evan did entity
appetite for it and probably won't all
you always hope.
Um,
I this little son of mine who's now
four,
his name is tad and he,
the week or two ago,
yeah,
I said I was going on a book tour and he
said no about what,
and I explained what the things they
carried was and for the first time he
had,
he had encountered out of my mouth the
word war in a personal way.
That is probably heard me say it before
he said war.
I mean,
you mean really killing people with for
real.
And so for real you said really?
I mean really killed people that I began
by saying and now people are getting in
disagreements and trying to simplify it.
But the astonishment on a four year
old's face that people are killing one
another man.
He said,
for what?
And boy that was hard to articulate an
answer to it.
I didn't have a header.
You're know,
they didn't have an answer the answer I
believe they had.
And it was like,
I don't know.
I don't really know for what.
Uh,
I was,
I was the lime of person who has thought
about this stuff my entire adult life.
I really haven't yet plumbed the for
wetness of,
of killing people.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't think I ever will.
Plumbing one of the huge things,
of course there's,
there's no draft and the people are
fighting,
are in the armed forces out of volition
and got her own,
we'll decisions.
And that's pretty huge.
It attracts a certain temperament that
wasn't mine.
That kind of can do macho,
adventurous,
uh,
temperament.
Then of course,
patriotism feeds in very strongly as
well.
Uh,
that's,
that's a pretty big difference from the
people who went to fight.
I mean,
there were many volunteers.
Of course I went to Vietnam,
but there were,
the bulk of us were drafted you,
so probably more or less went
reluctantly and,
uh,
and my case a lot more than less.
And so the two wars are being fought by
American soldiers.
I need side that have pretty different
temperaments.
And I,
for example,
did an article offer a big magazine
where I was sent to Brooke Army Medical
Center in San Antonio where the
terrible,
uh,
amputees or Sandton and burn victims,
and I felt great compassion for these
young men and one young woman,
but auto,
they're miles there.
There,
there was,
there was no,
none of the irony that accompanied the
war from my,
my generation.
Uh,
there's no questioning of the rectitude
of the war whatsoever.
It was just,
it wasn't even a thought about it for
far as I could tell if I quit.
No response to my question is,
do you ever wonder about there were no
weapons of mass destruction?
Did that bother you?
And the answer was in uniformly from
many,
many miles a flat,
no,
it doesn't bother me.
Don't even think about it.
But even that,
don't think about it.
It wasn't,
there was just no,
it doesn't bother me.
Um,
there was none of the edgy feel of
questioning or of ambiguity was that
certainty thing we began with.
It was there and those young people's
needs are horribly maim people,
horribly wounded.
But,
uh,
instead coming out of their mouths were,
were words such as wounded warrior and
war against global terror.
It was going to military sloganeering
had,
was part of their,
who they were and that,
that was one another one of the
differences from my,
from my time,
one of the odd things when the guest,
they,
one of the great ironies is that the
things they carried is a book is one of
the things being carried around Iraq and
Afghanistan and finding out that book is
passed around from soldier to soldier.
And which gives me a little bit of hope
that at least they're getting something
from another point of view and which was
mine and that,
that's,
that's good for me.
I don't know enough.
Um,
I saw such a simple minded guy.
I mean,
I just assume that in most ways there's,
there's no difference,
uh,
the faces here younger and the bodies
are leaner and because like the habits
are better than in my generation.
Nobody smokes anymore or very few.
Not Everybody.
They know about the right foods to eat.
Everybody looks a little sleeker than in
my,
or the girls look prettier and the guys
look tougher and tougher,
but buffer.
Um,
but aside from that,
I mean,
I'm like,
fuck,
I can hang out with college kids or
people in their 20s and feel utterly at
home and in,
in a way that I don't think I could have
felt at home where I 26 hanging out with
some,
you know,
it was Kurt Vonnegut,
her,
I think I would felt ill at ease,
but there was a poised among young
people that,
uh,
really does astonish me,
really astonishes me that way.
People can,
can uh,
do something.
I was so difficult for me,
so I'm not sure what to say exactly.
I don't think I hate it.
I fear it more than anything.
It's uh,
because you're,
you're,
you're put on the spot too,
are articulate things about something in
progress that,
that have the danger of freezing you
that as you say it enough times,
I'm doing this and then you damn well
better do it.
He started telling yourself all,
I've said,
I'm going to write this book and it's
going to be that kind of book and it
freezes.
It freezes you.
Are you,
you're reluctant to go beyond it or
pushing another direction with the same
book.
Having said that,
I,
I know enough about what I'm working on
to say that it's a book about being an
older father.
I'm 63 and I got these two young kids
and I can say that it's about some of
the stuff that I was writing about with
the things they carried.
The sense of your own mortality is
presses in on you in a war.
You know,
you know,
you,
you know intellectually you're going to
die someday,
but in a war you're reminded pretty
often and it was right at you.
And I feel that way is an older father.
I imagine,
where am I going to be 10 years from
now?
I mean,
basketball is going to be tough and will
I even be alive?
And um,
the two little boys or so,
uh,
no,
nothing of tombstones and uh,
nothing of the tick of biology are,
you know,
are facing it as I am.
And there's a sadness to it that's has,
that's accompanied by an exhilaration of
the moments matter.
And I got,
I'm taking advantage of them,
which is what I meant earlier about
writing that I'd rather,
I mean,
I could die tomorrow and I as a writer
be content with four or five of the
books I've written as being good,
but I can't die and be content about
these two unformed lives or aren't.
They're too young to be good.
And I want to try to be there to watch
him become good and to do what I can to
help.
And,
um,
so I'm writing with that,
but it's funnier than that funder.
Funny things in it too.
And the discovery of language and,
uh,
the storytelling part of the book is
about the stories I tell these kids.
Um,
there's sources,
uh,
partly in the world of now and partly in
the world of long ago.
What do I carry?
I carry a lot of years.
I feel that our,
that's not all bad.
It's partly bad.
I carry a,
what I think I probably was probably
come through in this talk we've had
today as a kind of delight and in doing
what I do and a believer in doing what I
do along with a sadness about doing what
I do.
Um,
because two decades later,
I'm fielding many of the questions about
war that I fielded all those years ago
and said,
mom,
my God,
you know,
that sort of back where we were.
And then some that that's feels like a
tangible burden.
Um,
but I carry with me these two kids I
mentioned.
And even though they're not physically
here,
they are.
They're all around me and the person I
become and they're living inside me.
And,
uh,
I carry a slight,
palpable feeling of obligation to,
uh,
do justice to the savagery I witnessed
and the senselessness of it.
And,
uh,
the,
um,
the sadness of it and it would,
so that sense of obligation is with me,
especially on occasion is like,
like this one we're doing,
trying to talk lucidly about this stuff.
After you do justice to chip,
I muddy and to the ghosts of the dead
Vietnamese and get Americans,
especially their mothers and dads who
are still bearing the burden,
even though their kids are along that,
I doubt they go to sleep many nights
without some poor woman in Orlando or
remembering or,
or Sana 40 years ago that she never got
the ever hold again and there.
That's pretty solid,
solemn obligation.